when i was doing stand-up originally i
mean kennison was the guy right and so
you know when i'm in a club and then
kennison's on i just think i should stop
being a comedian right it's like it it
can actually defeat you to see somebody
great at their craft
you know i sometimes would look at
kennison and go oh my god this guy's
light years ahead of anyone how does
anybody ever go into stand-up comedy
when there's kennison yeah i think about
him every day one of the most brilliant
comics comic minds everything i used to
see him when the crowd didn't know who
he was right and that was a whole
different thing right we did a comic
relief benefit in 86 and and no one
really knew who kinnison was yet maybe
he had been on hbo a little bit but at
this charity event he comes on
and does the greatest hits of kinnison
right and then he tears the roof off the
place and it had a bit hard for you to
see it was for me to see a great comedy
mind like that and i knew sam pretty
well to see him destroy himself the way
he did because i saw him go out many
nights when he was drunk and it really
killed me and go god have those kind of
gifts and to and to just abuse yourself
the abuse is crazy right i mean it just
doesn't make sense well yeah especially
when it's in slow motion
when when somebody is uh struggling and
everyone knows he's struggling and
everyone's trying to help and you
realize oh at some point uh
people have to figure out how to do it
but i think he was sober at the end of
his life yeah he was which is really the
tragedy of it which is he really got it
together yeah but but what's weird about
comedy now i don't know if you think
this is the case there really aren't any
wild men
anymore no there's no in like insane
people in comedy everyone's really good
and i think comedians are probably
better for the most part but where are
the lunatics maybe the comedians are
better at covering their insanity but
but insanity should be embraced like
andy kaufman seemed insane yes i don't
know if he was or wasn't but he seemed
insane uh kennison seemed to say die
seemed insane everyone said bob
goldthwait seems crazy yeah uh even i
remember the first time i saw howie
mandel on the merv griffin show i
thought he was mentally ill i mean it
was it was great there were the crazy
guys right and that's uh it's sort of
everyone wants to be now the snarky
harvard type guy the one thing about
kennison was i saw him one night just
come on and do all new material he's
just riffing off the top of his head
great
you